et pour débriefer cette conférence de
presse de vladimir poutine sur ce
plateau claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales bonsoir claude
plusieurs sorties un de vladimir poutine
je vais en énumérer une une ou deux ce
n'est pas nous qui menace en quelqu'un
est ce que c'est nous qui sommes allés
là bas aux frontières des états unis est
également c'est à l'occident de fournir
des garanties de sécurité comment
interpréter ces propos de vladimir
poutine face à 500 journalistes donc
deux jours après d'autres propos tenus
cette fois ci face à des hauts
dignitaires du ministère russe de la
défense quand il a dit la russie
répondra de manière militaire et
technique aux menaces occidentales je
vois que les propos du président poutine
ont le mérite de clarifier la situation
ce que veut le président de la russie
c'est une garantie de sécurité de la
part des états unis et dans un premier
temps en tout cas de personne d'autre il
en a d'ailleurs parlé à joe biden dans
l'entretien qu'ils ont su par voie
numérique et apparemment effectivement
il a obtenu que joe biden désigne un
négociateur de haut niveau monsieur
poutine a également désigné un
négociateur de haut niveau et les deux
se rencontreront des vues début janvier
à genève ça veut dire qu'il y aura un
groupe à haut niveau qui discutera de
l'établissement de conditions de
sécurité pour la russie mais aussi pour
les états unis bien entendu et on
reprend les négociations d'armes ce
contrôle c'est déjà ce que monsieur
poutine avait obtenu le 15 juin à genève
lorsqu'il avait obtenu que tous les
traités qui avait été détricoté par
trunks des traités d'armes ce contrôle
entre la russie et les etats unis
puissent revoir le jour sous une forme
ou sous une autre par conséquent ça sera
une négociation sans doute difficile
mais
effectivement je crois que les états
unis ne sont pas fermés à l'idée une
négociation de ce type c'est une
négociation bilatérale entre les
etats-unis et la russie est
effectivement monsieur poutine a dit il
ya déjà des missiles américains qui sont
en roumanie et en pologne je ne veux pas
qu'ils aient missile américain en
ukraine ces missiles mettront huit ou
dix minutes s'il était utilisé pour
arriver à moscou évidemment ça crée une
inégalité stratégique fondamental que
nous ne pouvons pas accepter et qui
n'existait pas dans le monde bipolaire
d'avant qui avait fabriqué ces traités
d'armes ce contrôle entre les états unis
et l'union soviétique ou entre les états
unis et la russie les propos forts donc
tout un de dieu vladimir poutine
d'ailleurs à l'instant un londres
condamnent je cite la rhétorique
agressive et incendiaire du kremlin et
vladimir poutine a quand même jugé je
cite positives les premières et actions
américaines aux exigences russes pour
résoudre la crise russo occidentale
autour de l'ukraine au qu'est ce qu'on
va vers vers l'apaisement vers une
désescalade avec les fameuses
négociations dont il parlait oui parce
que c'est les états unis qui sont en
cause effectivement les fusées ou les
missiles dont parle la dîmière poutine
ils n'appartiennent pas à d'autres pays
européens qui n'ont pas d'ailleurs
puisque même s'il s'agit de pays
nucléaires comme la grande-bretagne
comme la france il n'utilise pas ce type
de missile il utilise des sous marins
ils utilisent des avions pour véhiculer
leur force de frappe atomique par
conséquent le seul le seul enjeu c est
ce qu ils étaient les etats-unis se
prêteront à cette négociation
on va le voir c'est une négociation qui
sera très long sade et plaira sans doute
aux européens qu'ils ne seront pas
partie à cette négociation et sade et
plaira sans doute aussi à certains
membres de l'otan qui verront les balles
passées et qui vivront cette négociation
se poursuivre dans le courant de l'année
2022 pour aboutir espérons le un
résultat
interrogé également sur la répression de
l'opposition russe vladimir poutine a
jugé qu'il ne s'agissait pas de museler
des détracteurs mais deux juguler des
opérations d' influence étrangère de
quelle influence s'agirait-il oui alors
bon c'est vrai qu'aux états unis il ya
une loi qui oblige les diverses
institutions étrangères a déclaré si
elles ont les financements qui viennent
de l'étranger donc la difficulté de
langage et celle d'agent de l'étranger
qui est une une connotation péjorative
car qui dit agent d'étrangers dit
espionnage naturellement dans le langage
courant en réalité ce qu'il s'agit de
savoir c'est si ces organismes reçoivent
des financements de l'étranger point
final et effectivement que ces
financements soient déclarait alors un
certain nombre d'institutions considère
que ça gêne leurs activités en russie
d'autres s'en accommode une troisième
catégorie négocié avec les autorités
russes pour voir dans quelles conditions
elles peuvent opérer il ya une autre
question sur les libertés publiques et
sur la liberté de la presse une question
qui a été posée par leurs représentants
de l'école moscou qui était la question
de madame politovskaïa pourquoi est ce
que on ne connaît pas toujours les
assassins de journalistes d'opposition
et la réponse de la lumière poutine a
été mais il ya eu des enquêtes
judiciaires et les gens que l'on a
trouvé à qui on a trouvé une
responsabilité ont été condamnés bien
sûr at il ajouté ce ne sont peut-être
pas toujours les commanditaires les
commanditaires ultime de l'opération
mais si la justice trouve les
commanditaires ultime eh bien ils seront
également condamné
il ya eu 55 à sion a eu beaucoup de
questions lors de ces 82 conférence de
presse est évidemment il était question
aussi du coc vide 19 avec cette
cinquième vague qui touche de nombreux
pays notamment l'europe le président
russe assure que son pays était mieux
préparé à la pandémie que des économies
plus développé dans le monde la
croissance attendue est de 4,5 pour cent
que mal analysé la gestion russe de de
la pandémie alors que le vario mikron
fait frémir le monde alors c'est une
gestion qui a été assez complexe parce
qu'elle était en grande partie
décentralisée est à dire que le
gouvernement central prenait des mesures
mais qu'il déléguait l'adaptation de ces
mesures naturellement aux différentes
régions et à dire aux différents
gouverneurs on a vu à diverses reprises
d'ailleurs que le maire d'hem de moscou
quelle est la gloire derner prenez des
mesures beaucoup plus dures que le
gouvernement central parce qu'il
estimait que c'était nécessaire et que
ça s'imposait donc une gestion assez
assez souple et diversifiée mais je
pense que ça va continuer avec le
nouveau variant mais effectivement on va
dire poutine a surtout fait valoir les
résultats économiques
vous venez de le dire le pnb la
croissance du pnb qui efface la
décroissance de l'an dernier à taux de
chômage qui est assez bas en moyenne
4,3 pour cent des réserves de la banque
centrale qui ont plutôt augmenté ça
c'est là peut-être pas dit vraiment mais
c'est dû aussi au fait d'où le prix des
hydrocarbures a considérablement monté
et quand le prix des hydrocarbures
montrent évidemment c'est bon pour les
réserves de la banque centrale russe et
puis il a aussi parlé des programmes de
son gouvernement programme
d'infrastructures programmes sociaux il
a pointé du droit du doigt le problème
démographique en disant que la peut-être
que la politique de la famille il
n'avait pas totalement réussi puisque on
n'assiste pas à un redressement de la
deûle à la de la démographie russe et il
a dit très clairement que 145 145000 147
millions d'habitants n'était pas
suffisant pour un espace aussi vaste
87 millions d'actifs ce n'était pas
suffisant pour faire fonctionner
l'économie russe et ça c'est un point
intéressant enfin un peu une critique de
son gouvernement d'ailleurs il a aussi
critiqué sur des questions ponctuelles
telles ou telles gouverneur ou tel ou
tel maire puisque on on voyait bien que
quand les journalistes locaux posé des
questions très concrètes et bien il
disait je vais en parler au responsable
dès ce soir où dès demain matin au
responsable local merci beaucoup comme
dangereux présents pour votre analyse je
rappelle que vous êtes expert en
relations internationales